did you have any concerns about turning
your book into a TV series because I
don't know are you ever afraid they'll
change it or alter like how you did it
you know yeah oh they're always going to
change it and they should I mean it
needs to be the best TV show it can be
yeah uh I wasn't really worried about
that I I knew that I had chosen the
right people as partners and I knew they
were going to do a good job but yeah no
one's ever heard of Reese Witherspoon's
yeah well I really took a chance on her
yeah but uh but the thing that all of us
like I remember having a very early
meeting and it was like look we're gonna
find this band we're gonna figure it out
we're gonna figure out the music
um I don't it's going to be really hard
to find Daisy Jones that was the thing
it was gonna be really hard to find
Daisy Jones and it was like how are you
gonna find someone who's that
charismatic how are you going to find
someone who's that magnetic how are you
going to find someone who can be so you
know
complicated but at the same time draw
everyone to her and uh and then they
start casting I think it was like maybe
two weeks later I get an email there's
no
body of the email it's just a subject
line and it just says Riley Keough is
Daisy Jones question mark and I just
wrote back I mean there was an expletive
in what I said so I'll just paraphrase
thank you which was like absolutely yes
we have to do it and and from that
moment on everyone just felt like the
bar was so high with Riley being cast
that everyone else had to be that good
and I thought at some point they were
going to drop the ball on that but they
they really didn't and it started with
you
[Music]
[Applause]
songs or your babies right these
characters so I can imagine that's hard
to be like who's gonna not screw this up
it's like yeah yeah well and you do you
you come to care about them so much and
I could tell you everything that Daisy
would do or wouldn't do or what Billy
would do or wouldn't do and you want to
make sure one of the people who are
adapting it understand those things but
then also the people who are playing it
see the same thing in it that you see in
it and I just feel really I
like feel like it's pinched myself
dreaming that this cast is not only that
all of you are so right for the roles
that you're playing but also it's just
so clear and it was clear from band camp
and I feel like it's even clearer now
like you guys just like each other and
you get along you have a chemistry that
like you know it's just kind of funny
though because
two of the characters don't get along
and then right well you know they
certainly have done the dating competing
yeah but um but it's interesting yeah
yeah right yeah yeah
it happens because the chemistry is I
think what what makes a TV show a lot of
times yeah and like watching them is
just in the final product chemistry yeah
that's everything I agree
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]